IT IS TIME TO PLAY STAR WORDS!
(CHEERING, WHOOPING)
A LONG TIME AGO, IN A GALAXY
NEAR SAN FRANCISCO, GEORGE LUCAS
INVENTED A WAR THAT HAPPENED IN
THE STARS.
SIX BLOCKBUSTER MOVIES AND
MILLIONS OF FANS LATER, WE STILL
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THE HELL R2-D2
WAS SAYING, SO IN ANTICIPATION
OF THE FIRST-EVER DIGITAL
RELEASE OF THE STAR WARS
FRANCHISE ON FRIDAY, APRIL 10,
WE HAVE BEEN GIVEN A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY-- WE ARE FINALLY
GONNA FIND OUT WHAT R2 WAS
SAYING.
TO HELP US WITH THIS SEEMINGLY
INSURMOUNTABLE TASK, PLEASE
WELCOME, ALL THE WAY FROM THE
FOREST MOON OF ENDOR, THE
GALAXY'S MOST DECORATED
ASTROMECH DROID, R2-D2!
>> YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: YES, THANK YOU.
RIGHT HERE.
>> YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH.
>> YEAH!
>> HARDWICK: THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US, R2.
>> (BEEPS)
>> HARDWICK: YOU ARE TOO MUCH.
YOU KNOW, UH... I HOPE YOUR
FLIGHT WAS OKAY.
>> (BEEPS)
>> HARDWICK: THEY LOST YOUR
LUGGAGE?
>> (BEEPS)
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT.
WELL, UH...
THIS IS HOW THIS GAME'S GONNA
WORK-- COMEDIANS, I AM GONNA
SHOW YOU AN EASILY-LICENSED
STILL FROM THE NEW DIGITAL
RELEASE OF STAR WARS...
AND YOUR JOB IS TO TELL THE
AUDIENCE AT HOME WHAT YOU THINK
R2 WAS ACTUALLY SAYING DURING
THAT SCENE.
ALL RIGHT, R2, YOU GOOD?
>> (BEEPS)
>> HARDWICK: OKAY, GOOD.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF THEM ARE
PROTOCOL DROIDS.
UH...
>> (BEEPS)
>> HARDWICK: WELL, THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO TRY THEIR BEST.
>> (BEEPS)
>> HARDWICK: TAKE IT DOWN A
NOTCH.
ALL RIGHT, IF R2 LIKES YOUR
ANSWERS, THEN YOU'RE GONNA GET
POINTS:
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: IF HE DOES NOT LIKE
YOUR ANSWERS, YOU'RE GONNA GET
NO POINTS.
>> (WHINING BEEP)
>> HARDWICK: SO SAD.
SO SAD.
>> IT IS SO CUTE.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT, I KNOW
THIS IS THE BIGGEST CELEBRITY
YOU GUYS HAVE EVER MET AND I'M
SURE YOU'RE GONNA BE NERVOUS.
LET'S BEGIN.
FIRST UP, R2 STARES OUT THE
WINDOW AT THE END OF "EMPIRE".
(BELL DINGS)
WHAT WAS R2 SAYING IN THIS
SCENE, MATT MCCARTHY?
>> DUDE, BACK UP, THAT'S YOUR
SISTER.
>> THAT WAS GOOD.
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS TO MATT
MCCARTHY.
UH, JAMIE.
>> 'TWAS THE NIGHT BEFORE
COMIC-CON.
>> HARDWICK: MM-HMM.
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
>> OH, THANK YOU.
>> HARDWICK: HERE WE HAVE HAN
SOLO SURRENDERING THE... TO THE
IMPERIAL TROOPS ON THE MOON OF
ENDOR, RIGHT THERE.
(BELL DINGS)
UH, WHAT'S R2 SAYING, MATT
MCCARTHY?
>> UH, REMEMBER WHEN THIS GUY
CRASHED THE MILLENNIUM FALCON ON
A GOLF COURSE?
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, POINTS.
JAMIE.
>> UH, THROW YOUR HANDS IN THE
AIR AND WAVE 'EM LIKE YOU JUST
DON'T CARE THAT YOU'RE WEARING A
TINY LITTLE VEST.
IT'S SO LITTLE.
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS, POINTS.
>> THANK YOU.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT UP, R2 WATCHES
AS LUKE PRACTICES HANDSTANDS.
WHAT'S HE SAYING?
(BELL DINGS)
MATT.
>> IS ANYONE PLANNING ON
CLEANING ME?
I'M VERY EXPENSIVE.
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
R2 POINTS.
JAMIE.
>> UH, LET ME KNOW IF ANY LUNCH
MONEY SHAKES OUT OF THOSE
POCKETS, 'CAUSE MAMA'S CRAVING A
TWIX.
>> HARDWICK: ALL RIGHT.
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
PETE HOLMES.
>> YEAH, YEAH, THAT'S NICE.
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
NEXT UP, WE HAVE R2 BACK ON
TATOOINE WITH MR. AND MRS.
SKY-VADER, UH, RIGHT THERE.
(BELL DINGS)
MATT.
>> DO YOU THINK WE CAN FIND SOME
SHADE?
I'M R2-D2, NOT SPF 100.
>> HARDWICK: HOW ABOUT THAT?
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS FROM R2.
UH, JAMIE.
>> GUYS, I SWEAR WE PARKED IN
P5.
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: POINTS FROM R2.
PETE.
>> OOH, THEY'RE LOOKING GOOD.
THIS THIRD WHEEL IS NOT A FOOT.
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: OH, POINTS.
>> OH, WOW.
>> HARDWICK: AND LASTLY BUT NOT
LEASTLY, WE HAVE A PHOTO OF R2
WITH THE D-O-DOUBLE-G HIMSELF.
(BELL DINGS)
MATT.
>> WE SHOULD TOTALLY START A
PODCAST TOGETHER.
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: YES.
PETE.
>> SNOOP, I AM YOUR FATHER.
>> (CHIRPY BEEPING)
>> HARDWICK: YOU GOT POINTS,
THERE.
>> YEAH.
>> HARDWICK: YOU GUYS DID VERY
WELL-- NO ONE GOT NO POINTS THIS
ENTIRE ROUND, I WAS VERY HAPPY.
EVERYONE DID-DID A GREAT JOB.
>> I KNEW HE'D LIKE ME, I'M-I'M
C-3PETE HOLMES.
>> HARDWICK: UH...
>> (WHINING BEEP)
>> HARDWICK: OH, PETE.
>> R2.
>> LOOK HOW DISAPPOINTED HE IS.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH, MAN, I'M SICK
OF HIS BULL[BLEEP], TOO.
YOU'RE THE FIRST PERSON TO HAVE
THE COURAGE TO SAY IT, R2.
>> SHOW US THE HOLOGRAM OF
TUPAC.
>> (BEEPS)
>> HARDWICK: THAT DOES IT FOR
STAR WORDS.
DON'T FORGET TO DOWNLOAD THE
STAR WARS DIGITAL MOVIE
COLLECTION-- IT'S AVAILABLE
RIGHT NOW.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, PLEASE
HELP ME THANK R2-D2!
YAY!
AMAZING.
BYE, R2.